burnt ланга
німецький політик та соціал-демократи цієї
так вже купу документації міжнародні
турніри в європарламенті вин 1 ст їх
хтось допомагає українським колегам
реформувати верховну раду tempish ще
реформи закінчені обсідні я поважаючого у
року про базу асоціацію і ціна тому ще
ми хочемо у і дали розвивалися а там ми
зараз і її вдома в Україні ще ви означає
і рахунком можна поліп шитів державний
системі , боротьби з корупцією та з місця
не інституту генерального прокурора
економічніше реформа економічне зростання
б струм стікаючи зрощення відомо запас
печінки та державну тілесність у британії
регіоналізації суботу для born to ланге
цпш поїздка до києва та вени шема
пізнаємо це я даремно їм верховної ради
бейка ми блокуванням трибуни обертанням
бізнесу та влади то випад до ми так
званому кнопку зручності ланга мало що
ванною в польщу черв'як на діалог yax
представлені до ми правда людині
літії такі позиції
роботи у групи ланга ніж алла група
входи до складу спеціальної місії
бік і на базі меморандуму який
верховна рада та європарламент підписав та
всього літа зароблю українського
парламенту вуста жити і в рамадан скіс
встиг павлом і ronal активіст руку
чесно займається моніторингом
діяльності Верховної Ради з 2011 року на
його думка
європарламент у польську черву може
допомогти у верховній раді мало води ти
ефективну роботу
їй і комітеті нікому просто не часто
справляються у коли ці ось америці
перекачані в колишньому главі верховної
раді і
з реквізити не знаєте чого тут може
бути обидва гранта black есеньке а по
консультації про звільнення курсу
електронна система так може і
європейський зворушений
європейські чи то українські політики
обіцяють ще пекельний грім від чоловіка без
порошку дно скаже і
за всіма етапами трансформації верховної
раді